los geht's ab ins Restaurant der Zukunft
riesige Deckenhöhen wunderschönes Design
klare Linien absolut modern es lag so
etwas in der Luft na ja dann haben wir
uns auf unsere Fahrschule gesessen und
sind in den ersten Raum Gefahren den
Ocean Raum
[Musik]
auch die erste Speise die wir hatten die
einfach versteckt war in unserem Stuhl
war sehr lecker und dann ging es in den
nächsten Raum und schon beim Reinfahren
haben wir gesehen das ist ganz klar
japanischer Stil schaut euch das alleine
an und wir probieren
man merkt wirklich das sind Zutaten
höchster Güte Nigiri mit gerösteter
Paprika absolut vollmundig und jetzt
haben wir noch eine Sache übrig den dem
sum mit reradschaft und wir probieren
alter Schwede zu dem Zeitpunkt nach dem
umamiraum waren wir so kurz vorm
Höhepunkt weil was dann abging war krass
leider durfte nicht gefilmt werden